No, for those of you that have listened either from the beginning or you tuned in partway and you went back to the backlog and you've listened to every episode, you are our most important listeners. Not your mom who tunes in every once in a while. Absolutely not, Bryce. She is our legal counsel. Don't get me wrong. But our most important listeners are the ones that listen to all our episodes. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 170 recorded on February 22nd, 2024. My name is Connor and today my co-host Bryce explains the relationship between VIN numbers and the HPX parallel execution model. I don't know What problem don't we have? Well, should I share my screen briefly?
不，对于那些从一开始就收听，或者中途加入并回头补听了每一集节目的听众，你们才是我们最重要的听众。不是那些偶尔才听一次的你妈妈。绝对不是，Bryce。她是我们的法律顾问。别误会我的意思。但我们最重要的听众是那些听过我们所有节目的听众。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 170 期，录制于 2024 年 2 月 22 日。我是 Connor，今天我的联合主持人 Bryce 将解释 VIN 码与 HPX 并行执行模型之间的关系。我不知道，我们有什么问题吗？好吧，我要简要分享一下我的屏幕吗？
Yeah Should I share my screen briefly? You should Let's go Oh, yes We certainly do not have a problem With how our company is doing Man, that was a crazy year
是啊，我要简要分享一下我的屏幕吗？你应该分享。我们开始吧。哦，是的，我们当然没有关于公司运营状况的问题。天哪，那真是疯狂的一年。
Largest market cap I think we're number four we're number four baby but at this point we're approaching two trillion we are less than 200 billion away from taking over saudi aramco can you believe it folks we're more valuable than Amazon in fifth, Alphabet in sixth, Meta in seventh, good old Warren Buffett, Berkshire Hathaway at number eight were even more valuable than him, folks. Yeah.
市值最大，我想我们排在第四位，我们是第四名，宝贝。但目前我们正接近两万亿，距离超越沙特阿美公司不到两千亿了。大家能相信吗？我们比排名第五的亚马逊、第六的 Alphabet、第七的 Meta，还有老牌的沃伦·巴菲特、排名第八的伯克希尔·哈撒韦公司更有价值，伙计们。是的。
Woo! Microsoft and Apple, number one and two, just to fill out the top eight. And I guess we'll do top 10. Oh, I didn't know that. TSMC is number 10? Yeah. And Eli Lilly. Eli Lilly. Here's a quiz, Bryce. What drug is Eli Lilly? eight and i guess we'll do top 10 oh i didn't know that tsmc is number 10 yeah and eli lily
呜！微软和苹果，第一和第二，刚好填补了前八名。我想我们还是做个前十名吧。哦，我不知道。台积电是第十名？是的。还有礼来公司。礼来公司。给你出个题，Bryce。礼来公司以什么药物闻名？八，我想我们还是做个前十名吧。哦，我不知道台积电是第十名？是的，还有礼来公司。
eli lily here's a quiz bryce what drug is eli lily famous for i don't know insulin i want to say yeah that's correct yeah wow i'm really really nailing the quizzes yeah yeah um you know it's i remember um when i joined nvidia inVIDIA like six years ago, and it was right after Volta was released, and it was before the big AI wave. And some people told me at the time, like, oh, you don't want to go work for one of the hardware companies because like NVIDIA and Intel, they don't pay as well.
礼来公司，给你出个题，Bryce。礼来公司以什么药物闻名？我不知道。胰岛素，我想说是这个。是的，那是对的。哇，我真的很擅长回答这些测验。是的，是的。嗯，你知道，我记得大约六年前我加入 NVIDIA 时，那是在 Volta 发布之后，在大规模 AI 浪潮之前。当时有些人告诉我，哦，你不想去硬件公司工作，因为像 NVIDIA 和英特尔，他们的薪水没那么高。
You should go work for like a Google or a Microsoft or an Apple. But, you know, I just thought I came to work here because I was so impressed with the people from NVIDIA that I interacted with on the C++ committee, Olivier Gouraud, Jared Halbrick, and Michael Garland. I was just so impressed by them that I just knew that this is the place I wanted to go work. And my background was in parallel programming. And it seemed to me like they were really the parallel chip company. And I was like, this is the place for me. And boy, boy, has it worked out.
你应该去像谷歌、微软或苹果这样的公司工作。但是，你知道，我之所以来这里工作，是因为我与 NVIDIA 在 C++ 委员会中接触过的人印象深刻，比如 Olivier Gouraud、Jared Halbrick 和 Michael Garland。我被他们深深打动了，所以我知道这就是我想去工作的地方。我的背景是并行编程。在我看来，他们确实是并行芯片公司。我就想，这就是适合我的地方。天哪，这真是太成功了。
That's up to you. But, you know, here's something you can leave in. So in 2011, when I was just a wee little kid, my parents encouraged me to, like, start saving. And, like, as part of that, they were like, you should take a couple hundred dollars of your money and just play around with some stocks. Just to, you know, not – don't put all your savings in your own investments of your own choice, but just so that you like learn a little bit about the market and just as a, um, I don't know, learning experience. And, uh, I don't remember all the stocks that I bought. I bought some that were like some solar cell companies and one like EV company, um, uh, all of which were like, like one of which was like a was a Chinese startup that I'm sure is no longer around.
这取决于你。但是，你知道，这里有些内容你可以保留。所以在 2011 年，当我还是个小屁孩的时候，我父母鼓励我开始储蓄。作为其中的一部分，他们说，你应该拿几百美元去玩玩股票。只是为了，你知道，不要把所有的积蓄都投入到你自己选择的投资中，而是为了让你从中学到一点关于市场的知识，作为一个，嗯，我不知道，学习经验。而且，我记不清我买的所有股票了。我买了一些像太阳能电池公司和一家电动汽车公司，嗯，所有这些公司中，其中一家是一家中国初创公司，我敢肯定它已经不存在了。
But then I also bought AMD and NVIDIA because I was at LSU at the time working on HPX, and I thought that they would be big winners in the future. And that was in 2011. And I couldn't have bought more than $100 or $200 of each. But a year or two later, I just sold all that and just moved everything into index funds with my financial advisor. And for a few years after that, I would look back at how had my portfolio done if I had not sold it. And I haven't done that in a number of years. And I don't even want to know how much if i had held that 200 of nvidia and uh in
但后来我也买了 AMD 和 NVIDIA，因为我当时在路易斯安那州立大学研究 HPX，我认为它们在未来会成为大赢家。那是在 2011 年。我每家买的肯定不超过 100 或 200 美元。但一两年后，我就把所有这些都卖掉了，并让我的财务顾问把所有资金转入了指数基金。在那之后的几年里，我会回顾如果我没有卖掉它们，我的投资组合会表现如何。我已经好几年没这么做了。我甚至不想知道如果我持有那 200 美元的 NVIDIA 和……
the 200 of amd stock from 2011 i don't even want to know how much it would be now yeah it's always hard looking back at that stuff uh yeah and just for just for context because i guess this is i mean it's pretty relevant for those that are listening on friday when this gets released but we are recording this the day prior to friday february 23rd i'm actually i'm going i'm going to my first uh like in-person company all hands meeting today because i'm at i'm in hillsborough oregon uh because my girlfriend's here for work and so i figured i'd tag along and go visit my colleagues who are here, who work on the NVIDIA HPC compiler. And they happen to have like a, you know, the CEO's not
200 美元的 AMD 股票从 2011 年到现在会值多少钱。是的，回顾那些事情总是很困难。嗯，为了背景说明，因为我想这对于周五节目发布时收听的人来说非常相关，但我们是在周五（2 月 23 日）的前一天录制的。我今天实际上要去参加我的第一次线下公司全员大会，因为我在俄勒冈州的希尔斯伯勒，因为我女朋友在这里工作，所以我想我顺便去拜访一下在这里工作的同事，他们负责 NVIDIA 的 HPC 编译器。他们碰巧有一个，你知道，CEO 并没有
doing the all hands here in Oregon, which is one of our satellite offices. But they have like a viewing party for everybody in the local office to tune into the all hands. And so I'm going to my first in-person all-hands. I've been here six years. I've never been to an all-hands in person. I remember when I was in headquarters, like a few times walking past the ongoing all-hands of being like, I can't, I don't have time for this. Like I got too much stuff to do right now.
在这里的俄勒冈分部主持全员大会，这是我们的卫星办公室之一。但他们为当地办公室的所有人举办了一个观看派对，以便收听全员大会。所以我正要去参加我的第一次线下全员大会。我在这里工作六年了。我从来没有亲自参加过全员大会。我记得在总部时，有几次走过正在进行的全员大会，心想，我不能，我没时间参加这个。我手头有太多事情要做了。
I think I've like maybe called into 102 102 but i haven't really ever like attended like an all hands meeting um so now i'm gonna attend an all hands meeting and i'm bringing bringing i got my dog here with me who's traveling with us and so she's gonna come to her first nvidia all hands meeting or her first nvidia all pause meeting all right so i got one comment to finish and then i've got a question. My first comment to finish was I was, I was given some context by the day that we were recording this because we were talking about market cap. NVIDIA, at least at this point in time, it is 1215 PM EST. So we're mid market. Market's been open for three hours and 15 minutes. We're up 15%
我想我可能拨入过 102 次，但我从来没有真正参加过全员大会。嗯，所以现在我要去参加一个全员大会了，我带着我的狗，它和我们一起旅行，所以它将参加它的第一次 NVIDIA 全员大会，或者说它的第一次 NVIDIA 全“爪”大会。好了，我有一个评论要结束，然后我有一个问题。我要结束的第一个评论是，我被我们录制这一天的背景所启发，因为我们谈到了市值。NVIDIA，至少在此时此刻，是东部时间下午 12:15。所以我们处于市场中期。市场已经开放了 3 小时 15 分钟。我们上涨了 15%
right now. So our market cap, we were ranked fourth at the beginning of the day. We'll probably be ranked fourth at the end of the day, but it's been a good day. But it's all ephemeral. It'll go down, it'll go up. My question now is, you realize that the All Hands is at 1 p.m. Eastern time and therefore 10 a.m. your local time, which means you have 45 minutes to get there, right? Well, yeah. I mean, I imagine I'll probably miss a little bit of it. And I do have to, you know, make slides during it because I'm giving a talk later in the day. Yeah. I mean, this is the beautiful thing about attending these things remotely, which is what I have. I've never been to an all hands in person and all hands doesn't need,
现在。所以我们的市值，我们在一天开始时排名第四。我们可能在一天结束时仍然排名第四，但这真是美好的一天。但这都是短暂的。它会下跌，也会上涨。我现在的问题是，你意识到全员大会是在东部时间下午 1 点，也就是你当地时间上午 10 点，这意味着你还有 45 分钟赶到那里，对吧？嗯，是的。我的意思是，我想我可能会错过一点点。而且我确实必须，你知道，在会议期间制作幻灯片，因为我当天晚些时候要发表演讲。是的。我的意思是，这就是远程参加这些会议的美妙之处，我以前就是这样。我从来没有亲自参加过全员大会，而且全员大会并不需要
doesn't require a hundred percent of the attention. And you know, if we're, if we're being honest, you can, especially if you're doing things that require compiling or running tests that, you know, have a little five minute or 10 minute loop. Perfect, perfect time to do that kind of stuff. Cause you can pay attention, hit the button and poof. Yeah. And I mean, I have all the content for my slides. I just need to take the code and put it into slide form and add a few notes. Yeah. So I actually, I have two topics for us today. All right. The first topic is I got a question from our most important listener, my mother, who apparently has told some of her friends about the podcast and they have listened.
不需要百分之百的注意力。而且你知道，如果我们诚实的话，你可以，特别是如果你正在做需要编译或运行测试的事情，你知道，有一个五分钟或十分钟的循环。这是做这类事情的完美时间。因为你可以注意听，按下按钮，然后砰。是的。我的意思是，我有幻灯片的所有内容。我只需要把代码放进幻灯片格式并添加一些注释。是的。所以我今天实际上有两个话题。好的。第一个话题是我收到了我们最重要的听众——我母亲的问题，她显然已经告诉她的一些朋友关于这个播客的事，他们也听了。
She's listened to a couple episodes, I think, too. Well, she's clearly not our most important listener if she doesn't listen to every episode. She's my mother. She's the most important listener. She's the most important listener. For those of you that have listened either from the beginning or you tuned in partway and you went back to the
我想她也听了几集。好吧，如果她不听每一集，她显然就不是我们最重要的听众。她是我母亲。她是最重要的听众。她是最重要的听众。对于那些从一开始就收听，或者中途加入并回头补听了
backlog and you've listened to every episode, you are our most important listeners. Not your mom who tunes in every once in a while. Absolutely not, Bryce. She is our legal counsel. Don't get me wrong. But our most important listeners are the ones that listen to all our episodes. So she sent me a text and she said, Dear ADSP, how are VIN numbers assigned to cars? And this is, I presume, a follow-up to, she must have seen our episode about how credit card numbers are issued and I also mentioned it to her. So for those who don't know, every car has a VIN number, which is an identifying number that gets issued to it.
每一集节目的听众，你们才是我们最重要的听众。不是那些偶尔才听一次的你妈妈。绝对不是，Bryce。她是我们的法律顾问。别误会我的意思。但我们最重要的听众是那些听过我们所有节目的听众。所以她给我发了一条短信，她说，亲爱的 ADSP，VIN 码是如何分配给汽车的？我想这应该是后续问题，她一定看了我们关于信用卡号码是如何发放的那一集，我也向她提过。所以对于那些不知道的人，每辆车都有一个 VIN 码，这是一个发给它的识别号码。
So, I did a little bit of research on this. And it's not, I think, as interesting an algorithmic question as the credit card numbers. Because one of the key things with the credit card numbers is that with the credit card numbers, you don't want them to be issued sequentially because you don't want them to be guessable. Because if they're guessable, then they're attackable, right? Then you can find out somebody's credit card number and maybe, you know, and if you can find out their credit card number and if maybe you have some way of telling from this, if they were issued sequentially, then maybe you could figure out
所以，我对此做了一些研究。我认为这不像信用卡号码那样是一个有趣的算法问题。因为信用卡号码的关键点之一是，对于信用卡号码，你不希望它们是按顺序发放的，因为你不希望它们是可以被猜到的。因为如果它们是可以被猜到的，那么它们就是可以被攻击的，对吧？然后你可以找出某人的信用卡号码，也许，你知道，如果你能找出他们的信用卡号码，如果也许你有某种方法从这些号码中判断出它们是否是按顺序发放的，那么也许你可以算出
roughly when the card was issued. And then if you knew what the typical expiration date length is for that card issuer, then you could figure out, you know, the credit card's expiration date, yada, yada. Maybe you could figure out the billing zip code and then you're able to, you know, to use that card number. So, obviously, with credit cards, you need to make sure that they're not issued in a predictable way. But not so much a problem with vehicle identifier numbers. Now, VIN numbers tend to differ from country to country, how they're issued. There are some, unsurprisingly, ISO standards for VIN numbers. I don't think we're going to purchase and look at those today. There's ISO... Ooh, the listeners want another PDF purchase for an obscene amount of money for
大约卡片是什么时候发放的。然后如果你知道该发卡机构的典型有效期长度，那么你就可以算出，你知道，信用卡的有效期，等等。也许你可以算出账单邮政编码，然后你就能，你知道，使用那个卡号。所以，显然，对于信用卡，你需要确保它们不是以可预测的方式发放的。但这对于车辆识别号码来说并不是什么大问题。现在，VIN 码在不同国家发放的方式往往不同。不出所料，有一些针对 VIN 码的 ISO 标准。我想我们今天不会去购买和查看那些标准。有 ISO……哦，听众们想要另一个为了 12 页内容而花费巨资购买的 PDF
12 pages so there's two standards uh there's iso 3779 which uh uh defines the like structure in the content in a VIN number and then iso 4030 which uh it says is about location and attachment, which I think is like where it should go on the car. And they are not just for cars, but also for towed vehicles, motorcycles, and things like scooters and mopeds, et cetera. And there's a couple of interesting things about VIN numbers that I think lead to some lessons about programming in general, and in particular, designing address systems. So, a VIN number isn't just solely a unique identifying number, just as a credit card number actually isn't solely a uniquely identifying number. Just as a credit card number actually isn't solely a uniquely identifying number. You know, the credit card number has some information embedded in it, like, you know, who the credit card issuer is. In the case of a VIN number, you have
所以有两个标准，ISO 3779，它定义了 VIN 码的结构和内容；还有 ISO 4030，它说是关于位置和附件的，我想这指的是它应该放在车上的什么位置。它们不仅适用于汽车，也适用于拖车、摩托车以及像踏板车和轻便摩托车等。关于 VIN 码有几件有趣的事情，我认为这引出了一些关于编程的教训，特别是设计地址系统。所以，VIN 码不仅仅是一个唯一的识别号码，就像信用卡号码实际上也不仅仅是一个唯一的识别号码。就像信用卡号码实际上也不仅仅是一个唯一的识别号码。你知道，信用卡号码中嵌入了一些信息，比如，你知道，谁是信用卡发卡机构。在 VIN 码的情况下，你有
the manufacturer identifier as part of it. And then there's a vehicle descriptor section which tells you like the general characteristics of the vehicle. And then there's a vehicle identifier section and that can be the just solely like a unique serial number. But a lot of manufacturers will include, you know, some things like the make, model, what engines in the car, some other details that are maybe specific to them will be embedded in that vehicle identifier section. The stated purpose of the vehicle identifier section is that it's supposed to be an indication that provides clear identification of a particular vehicle, whereas the vehicle descriptor section is supposed to provide an indication of the general characteristics of the vehicle. And so, the thing that I think is interesting for us to talk about in the context of programming is this notion of information
制造商标识符作为它的一部分。然后有一个车辆描述部分，它告诉你车辆的一般特征。然后有一个车辆识别部分，那可以仅仅是一个唯一的序列号。但许多制造商会包含，你知道，一些东西，比如品牌、型号、车里有什么引擎，一些其他可能对他们特定的细节会被嵌入到那个车辆识别部分中。车辆识别部分的既定目的是，它应该是一个提供特定车辆清晰识别的指示，而车辆描述部分应该提供车辆一般特征的指示。所以，我认为我们在编程背景下讨论的有趣之处在于这种在地址空间中嵌入信息的概念。这实际上是我非常熟悉的事情，因为过去我在俄亥俄州立大学研究 HPX，这个并行运行时系统。我那里的主要贡献是重新设计了一个我们称之为自适应全局地址空间的系统，这就是 HPX 的寻址空间。当时它是一个 128 位的地址空间。如果你考虑大多数系统上的本地内存地址空间，你通常会认为它就像，哦，好吧，那只是，你知道，它只是操作系统发出的指向某个内存位置的任意 64 位数字。但实际上，根据操作系统的不同，有些操作系统不仅仅是——它不仅仅是一个唯一的标识符。通常会有一个前缀，可能与你的特定进程相关联。尽管如今有了地址空间随机化，
embedded in address spaces. And this is actually something that I'm quite familiar with because back in the day, I worked on HPX, this parallel runtime system at OSU. And the thing that I, like my primary contribution there was redesigning a system that we called the adaptive global address space, which was HPX's addressing space. And at the time it was a 128-bit address space. And if you think about your like local memory address space on most systems, you typically think about that as like, oh, well, that's, you know, it's just some arbitrary, you know, 64-bit number that points to some memory location that the operating system issues. But actually, depending on the operating system, some operating systems don't just – it's not just like solely an identifier. There's usually some prefix there that's maybe associated with your particular process. Although these days with address space randomization,
本地内存地址的实际结构往往变得不那么可预测。但在 HPX 中，我们做了与信用卡系统和 VIN 系统类似的事情，那就是我们将有用的信息嵌入到地址本身中。特别是在 HPX 中，我们有这个 128 位的地址。低 64 位，我们用来嵌入本地内存地址。所以，在 HPX 的模型中，HPX 是一个分布式模型。因此，这些 128 位地址是系统中某个对象的全局地址。我们对那低 64 位所做的是，我们会嵌入本地地址，嘿，在这个，你知道，这是这个东西所在的任何特定系统上的内存地址。这非常有用，因为这意味着当你向特定的分布式对象路由请求时，你不必进行本地查找，即该对象在本地内存中的地址是什么。所以你可以取这个 128 位地址，你可以查看前 64 位，其中包含关于，嘿，这个东西在哪个节点上的信息？然后你可以向该节点分发一条消息。该消息可以使用指向该对象的本地指针。你不必去那个节点然后说，嘿，我在这个节点上。让我，你知道，让我去访问这个对象。我们实际上还嵌入了一些其他
it tends to be less predictable what the actual structure of a local memory address is. But in HPX, we did sort of the same sort of thing that the credit card system does and that the the VIN system does, which is that we embedded useful information into the address itself. And in particular, in HPX, we had this 128-bit address. And the lower 64 bits, we would use to embed a local memory address. So, in HPX's model, HPX was a distributed model. And so, these 128-bit addresses were global addresses to objects that would be somewhere in the system. And what we did with those lower 64 bits is we would embed the local address of, hey, on this, you know, this is the memory address on whatever particular
信息在这个地址里。我认为从编程语言的角度来看，最有趣的事情之一是我们把类型信息嵌入到了地址中。所以，在 HPX 的模型中，这个全局地址空间中的所有对象都是对象。它们是类。它不仅仅是原始内存，一切都是对象。所以每个对象都会有一个特定的类型，这些类型会在全局注册。因此，这些全局地址中的每一个都会嵌入类型，
system this thing lives on. And this was quite useful because this meant that when you were routing a request to a particular distributed object, you didn't have to do a local lookup of what's the address of this object in local memory. So you could take this 128-bit address, you could look at the top 64 bits, which had the information about, like, what node is this thing on? And then you could dispatch a message to that node. And that message could use the local pointer to that object. You didn't have to go to that node and then say, hey, I'm on this node. Let me, you know, let me go and access this object. And we actually embedded some other
这很有用，因为如果你想进行远程过程调用，你可以在分发消息之前进行一些类型检查，以确保你得到了正确地址、正确类型的对象。所以它就像这个嵌入了类型的胖指针。现在，HPX 有一个挑战，那就是它是一个活跃的全局地址空间。活跃的部分是对象可以为了负载平衡的目的从一个节点移动到另一个节点。所以我们处理它的方式是，本质上，如果一个对象从一个节点移动到另一个节点，我们不能改变地址，因为地址本身嵌入了关于它位于哪个节点以及该对象在该节点上的地址的信息。我们希望我们的系统具有一种我们称之为引用完整性的属性，这意味着如果你有一个引用，一个指向对象的指针，它总是有效的。即使这个东西在这个分布式地址空间中从一个地方移动到另一个地方，原始地址仍然有效。所以我们所做的是，如果一个节点收到一条消息
information in this address too. One of the most interesting things, I think, from a programming language perspective is we embedded typing information into the address. So, in HPX's model, all of the objects in this global address space were objects. They were classes. It wasn't just like raw memory, but everything was an object. And so every object would have a particular type, and those types would be registered globally. And so every one of these global addresses would have the type embedded in there,
指向一个特定的地址，而该地址已经移动了，该节点就会重定向到新的位置。然后最终通过缓存，每个人都会希望得到更新。当它进行重定向时，它还会向与它通信的人发送一条消息，说，嘿，这个东西已经移动了。把它放进你的地址缓存中，这样你就不用再打电话给我，让我把这个东西重定向到别的地方了，因为否则我最终可能会得到这个节点，它可能已经经历了高负载平衡，
which was useful because if you wanted to do like a remote procedure call, you could do some type checking to make sure that you've got an object of the correct address of the correct type before you even dispatch the message. So it was like this like fat pointer that embedded the type in it. Now, there was one challenge with HPX, which is that it was an active global address space. And the active part was that objects could move from one node to another node for load balancing purposes. And so the way that we handled that is that essentially we would, if an object moved from one node to another node, we couldn't change the address because the address itself has embedded in it information about what node it lives on and the address of the object on that node. And we wanted our system to have a property that we call referential integrity, which means that if you have a reference, a pointer to an object, that's always good. Even if the thing moves from one place to another place in this distributed address space, the original address remains good. And so what we did was we simply, if a node received a message
这就是为什么东西被从它那里移走的原因。然后如果它必须花所有这些时间把东西重定向到其他节点，嗯，那只会让负载平衡问题变得更糟。在全局地址中嵌入本地地址的另一个有用之处在于，它优化了其中一种快速情况，即如果我正在使用其全局地址访问一个对象，而该对象位于我所在的节点上，这是我在本地对象上工作的常见情况，我可以完全避免与寻址服务器进行任何通信，因为我可以看到，嘿，我有这个地址。我可以看到这个地址，这个对象所在的节点就是我当前的节点。而且有一种快速的方法我们可以
to a particular address and that address had moved, the node would just redirect to wherever the new place is. And then eventually through caching, everybody would hopefully get the update. And when it does the redirection, it would also send a message back to whoever communicated with it saying, hey, this thing's moved. Put this into your address cache so that you stop calling me and asking me to redirect this thing to somewhere else because otherwise I could end up with this node which was probably already experiencing high load balance,
在我们的系统中检查这一点。我们不必往返于全局寻址服务器。所以我知道这个对象是本地的，我知道它没有移动，我可以快速检查这一点。然后，嘿，因为我这里有本地地址，我不必去查找这个对象在哪里。我可以只从这个全局地址中取出本地地址并解引用它，砰，我就会在内存中得到一个实际的对象。我认为如今许多地址空间往往以某种方式嵌入这种有用的信息。你知道，很多人可能认为，哦，我们永远不需要超过 64 位的内存地址。但实际上，我们几乎肯定会在未来转向更宽的地址，因为随着处理器变得越来越复杂，我们看到越来越多的专用硬件和专用内存以及各种类型的内存，我认为我们将开始看到越来越多对
which is why stuff was moved away from it. And then if it has to be spending all this time redirecting things to other nodes, well, that's just going to make the load balance issue worse. And one of the other useful things about having the local address embedded in the global address was that it optimized one of the fast cases, which is if I'm accessing an object using its global address and the object lives on the node that I'm on, which is the common case that I'm doing work on a local object, I can completely avoid any communication with the addressing server because I can see, hey, I've got this address. I can see that this address, the node that this object lives on is my current node. And there's a fast way that we can
巧妙寻址系统的需求，我们在寻址系统中嵌入了各种信息。这将需要比我们目前拥有的更多的位数。哦，我们在 HPX 地址中嵌入的另一件有趣的事情是，在 HPX 中，所有对象的生命周期都由引用计数管理。地址本身会包含一定数量的引用计数。你所做的是，每次你把地址发送到另一个节点时，也就是每次你序列化地址并将其发送到其他地方时，你就会拆分引用计数。所以发送者保留一半的引用计数，接收者获得一半的引用计数。这样，当你向另一个节点发送消息时，你不必去调用全局寻址系统并说，嘿，增加引用计数。
check that in our system. We don't have to go round trip to the global addressing server. So I know that this object is local and I know that it hasn't moved and I can check that quickly. And then, hey, because I have the local address here, I don't have to go look up where this object is. I can just take the local address out of this global address and dereference it and boom, I'll have an actual object in memory. And I think a lot of address spaces these days tend to have this sort of embedded, useful information in some way, shape, or form. You know, a lot of people maybe think like, oh, we'll never need more than 64-bit addresses for memory. But actually, we almost certainly will in the future move to wider addresses because as processors become more complex and we see more specialized hardware and specialized memory and types of memories, I think that we'll start to see more and more of a
当你通信时，你避免了向对象的原始所有者发送额外的引用计数流量。所以这是一个非常巧妙的小技巧。本质上，这意味着这些地址，虽然它们具有引用完整性的属性，但当你比较这些地址时，你必须屏蔽掉引用计数位，因为那些总是会改变。因为我可以在一个地方拥有这个地址，它还剩下，你知道，128 个引用计数。然后在其他地方，也许我有一个地址，它是同一个地址，但我只剩下 32 个引用计数。这两个应该比较相等，因为它们是同一个地址。我只是在地址中有几个位，我在那里存储这个引用计数信息。
need for clever addressing systems where we have all sorts of embedded information in the addressing systems. And that will require more bits than we currently have. Oh, another interesting thing that we would embed in the HPX addresses is that in HPX, all of the objects had their lifetimes managed by reference counting. And the addresses themselves would have a number of reference counts in it. And what you would do is every time you send the address to another node, so every time you serialize the address and it gets sent over the wire to somewhere else, you split the reference count. So the sender keeps half of the reference count and the receiver gets half of the reference count. And this way, when you send a message to another node, you don't have to go and call the global addressing system and say, hey, increment the reference count.
所以，这是一个非常酷的系统。我当时非常，我非常，那是我写过的最好的代码之一，我想说。所以这一切都始于与 VIN 码的比较？是的，与 VIN 码。这些复杂的 HPX 花哨功能有多少与 VIN 码有关？嗯，HPX 地址系统中的所有花哨功能都是关于这个想法的，即我们要把有用的信息嵌入到地址中。所以地址是，是的，它是一个唯一的标识符，但它也有有用的信息。这适用于信用卡，VIN 码有，你知道，这个校验位的东西，给定一个 VIN 码，你可以，一些
You avoid having additional reference counting traffic back to the original owner of the object when you're communicating. And so that was a pretty clever little trick. And essentially, that meant that these addresses, while they had this property of referential integrity, when you were comparing these addresses, you had to mask away the reference counting bits because those would always change. Because I could have the address in one place where it has, you know, 128 reference counts left. And then on some other place, maybe I have an address where the same address, but where I only have 32 reference counts left on it. And those two should compare equal because they're the same address. I've just got this couple bits in the address where I'm storing this reference counting information.
VIN 码中的数字和信用卡号码中的一些数字是根据其他数字计算出来的校验位。所以，你可以进行这种快速检查，立即确定你拥有的地址是否完全是垃圾。比如，那是嵌入式信息的巧妙利用。而且，给定一个信用卡号码，你可以判断谁是发卡机构。你知道，就像你在网上看到一些网站，它们要求你选择 Visa、MasterCard 或 Amex。嗯，它们不必那样做。它们实际上可以从号码中推断出实体的类型，就像 HPX 给定一个地址，你可以确定它指向的对象的类型一样。所以，VIN 码到底是什么，它们只是存储关于
So, it's a pretty cool system. I was pretty, I was pretty, that was some of the best where I'm storing this reference counting information. So it was a pretty cool system. I was pretty, that was some of the best code I wrote, I would say. So this all started with a comparison to VIN numbers? Yeah, to VIN numbers. How much of this complicated HPX fanciness ties back to the VIN number? Well, all of the fanciness in the HPX address system was all about this idea of we're going to embed useful information into an address. So the address is, yes, it's a unique identifier, but it also has useful information. And that's applicable to credit cards and VIN numbers have, you know, this check digit thing where given a VIN number, you can, some of
车辆或卖方或什么的某些信息？是的，是的，关于车辆品牌和型号以及制造商的某些信息。里面还可以有其他一些东西。比如你可以看出汽车的车型年份。你可以看出，你知道，什么类型的引擎，比如汽车的一些特征是什么？比如它是，你知道，它是带有这个引擎或那个引擎的马自达 3 吗？它是哪个配置？有时甚至包括颜色等，这对于执法部门来说是有用且重要的，例如能够
the digits in the VIN number and some of the digits in a credit card number are check digits that are computed from the other digits. So, you can do this quick check to immediately determine whether or not the address that you have is complete garbage or not. Like, that's a clever use of embedded information. And also, given a credit card number, you can tell who the card issuer is. You know, like you see some websites out there where they ask you to select like Visa, MasterCard, or Amix. Well, they don't have to do that. They can actually infer that, the type of the the entity from the number just in the same way that an hpx given an address you can you can determine what the type of the object that it points to is so what and what is it about vin numbers they're just storing certain pieces of information about the
哦，你只是在发送 VIN 码，我可以判断，哦，我正在寻找一个，你知道，这个 VIN 码是一辆白色的丰田卡罗拉。这可以直接从 VIN 码中推断出来，而不必去查询某个数据库。或者更确切地说，我想说，HPX 的关键属性之一，我们嵌入所有这些信息的原因之一是为了避免不得不向全局服务器或位于其他地方的服务器发送查询，我们想要本地化信息的查找。VIN 码也让你做到这一点。你知道，每辆警车都可以有一台电脑，里面有一个所有 VIN 码解码的小数据库。然后，你知道，
vehicle or the seller or something yeah yeah certain information about like the make and model of the vehicle and the manufacturer. There's a few other things that can be in there. Like you can tell like the model year of the car. You could tell the, you know, what type of engine, like what are some of the features of the car? Like is it, you know, is it a Mazda 3 with, you know, this engine or that engine? Which trim is it? Sometimes even things like the color, et cetera, which is useful and important, for example, for law enforcement to be able to,
你可以直接把 VIN 码输进去。你不必去调用某个服务器并查找，你知道，这辆车的品牌和型号是什么，你可以直接把信息都放在一个小本地存储里，还有解码信息。是的，这很有用。顺便说一下，我从来没有拥有过车辆，这就是为什么我对所有这些东西了解得这么少。但回答我母亲最初的问题，也就是，它们是如何发放的。所以第一，它们是在汽车实际制造时分配的。大多数制造商只是按顺序发放它们。所以号码通常会指示什么……它实际上纯粹是数字的部分指示了这辆车是第几辆下线的。因为同样，没有安全需求去
oh, you're just sending around the VIN number and I can tell, oh, I'm looking for a, you know, this VIN number is a white Toyota Corolla. And that can just be inferred immediately from the VIN number without having to go and query some database. Or rather, I should say, like, one of the key properties of HPX, one of the reasons why we embedded all this information was to avoid having to send queries to a global server or to a server that lived somewhere else, that we wanted to localize the lookup of information. And VIN numbers let you do that too. You know, every police car can have a computer in it that has a little database of all of the decodings of VIN numbers. And then, you know,
随机化那部分。而且在某些国家和地方，当你必须在汽车制造出来时向某个政府机构注册 VIN 码时，制造商都会处理这些。而且近年来，为了适应某种未来的增长，在更新和现代化 VIN 系统方面做出了一些努力，至少在美国是这样。有趣。是的。请务必查看你的播客应用程序或 ADSP the podcast.com 上的节目说明
you can just type the VIN number in there. You don't have to go and call some server and look up, you know, what's the make and model of this car you can just have information can all be in a little local store and uh of decoding info yeah that is useful i've never for the record never owned a vehicle which is why i know so little about uh but all this stuff but to answer the the original question of my mother which is uh how are they issued um so one they are assigned when the car is actually manufactured. And most manufacturers just issue them sequentially. And so the number typically would indicate what... The actual part of it that's solely a number indicates what number of this car rolled off the factory line. Because again, there's no security need to
以获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“带有信息碎片的混乱”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
randomize that part of it there. And there is some, you know, in certain countries and places, the VIN number, when you have to like register it with some government agency when the car gets created and the manufacturers all take care of that. And there was, there was a, there has been some effort in recent years to update and modernize the VIN systems, at least in the U.S. to accommodate sort of future growth. Interesting. Yeah. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com
随机化那部分。在某些国家和地区，当车辆制造完成时，必须向政府机构注册车辆识别码（VIN），制造商会处理这些事宜。近年来，美国至少在更新和现代化 VIN 系统方面做出了一些努力，以适应未来的增长。很有趣。是的。请务必在您的播客应用程序或 ADSP the podcast.com 上查看这些节目笔记
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。低质量、高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。